today we have a chance to take it all
back we will whatever it takes whatever
it takes whatever it takes
hi everyone it's Charlie hopefully
you've had a chance to see Avengers
endgame by now it's been out for a
couple days there's so many questions
everyone has so this will be my video
breaking down the end of the film there
are so many things that they set up so
many questions that you guys had from my
review videos that I posted this week
there's so much stuff about the future
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe that
we'll have to talk about in the next
week so there'll be a bunch of videos
coming be sure to subscribe to get
everything if you're new to my channel
I'm also bringing back the Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway - all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment about the movie on the
video really big spoiler warning for
Avengers end game if you have not seen
it yet we'll be talking about the end of
the movie very specific step so careful
for spoilers what I'm gonna do is
because the end of the film is really
like the entire last hour of the film
I'm just gonna brush through the
unimportant stuff and hit the really big
beats so the three different Avengers
teams are successful in their attempt to
steal the Infinity stones from different
places earlier in their timeline
remember they're using Dragon Ball Z
time travel rules
so anything that they change in the past
won't affect their future it'll only
create alternate timelines alternate
realities for those points in time so
the ancient one sort of gives hope that
explainer tutorial on how time travel
works and how she's going to be doomed
in their reality if they don't bring the
time stone back we'll still go back
around to that in a second because that
gets into the Captain America scene
towards the end of the film but Ironman
makes a stark tech gauntlet to hold the
Infinity stones Hulk is the one to snap
everyone back because correctly by his
logic the original Infinity Gauntlet
almost killed Thanos when he used it and
he's naturally one of the most powerful
people in the universe so it's almost
fatal to anyone who's not a higher being
that tries to wield it
he also jokes that the Infinity Gauntlet
gives off a lot of gamma radiation so
it's almost as if I was made for this
wink wink from behind the camera because
gamma radiation the Hulk
professor Hulk snaps everyone back to
the current year which is 2023 five
years after the original snap everyone
who comes back has not aged a day and
for them it feels like they've only been
gone for a few moments
remember that because it's important for
spider-man related questions in
spider-man far from home we know the
snap works because Hawkeye's wife who
had been snapped suddenly calls him on
his phone and he's really happy but
secretly while this is all happening
evil nebula from 2014 has swapped places
with our nebula and then secretly
brought Thanos into present-day using
the time-travel platform and our nebulas
Pym particles that's how we shrunk his
ship down and brought it through the
portal so as they're cheering themselves
yay our snap words Thanos ship goes back
to regular size starts bombarding the
Avengers base and that's basically when
the beginning of the end of the movie
starts and it's that entire last battle
for the last hour of the film there's an
ongoing game of hot potato keep away
with the stark tech Infinity Gauntlet
that starts with Hawkeye but then winds
up being spider-man after they all come
back Doctor Strange and Wong who had
never been brought back by the snap
portal in pretty much every Marvel
character you've ever seen in any MCU
film to fight with the Avengers against
Thanos army evening the odds you have
the thick with two seas Thor dual
wielding Mjolnir that he had stolen from
the events of Thor the dark world and
storm breaker in present day and now
because we have a mule near in
present-day it allows Captain America to
wield it paying off that moment from
Avengers age of Ultron it's a big comic
book moment both times when I watched it
everyone in my theater cheered so loud
not as loud as Thor cheered though he
says I knew it find someone who looks at
you the way that Thor looks at Captain
America wielding Mjolnir there's a lot
of questions about what's going on with
Gamora and nebula in present day now
because of all the time-travel so
because Thanos from 2014 comes into
present day with a younger nebula and a
younger Gamora
before the events of guardians of the
galaxy Gamora never joined their team so
she never fell in love with star-lord
but she still has that sisterly bond
with nebula so she is kind of a good
character she helps turn her they try to
stop danos as much as they can during
the fight but after the fight because
she has no allegiance to the guardians
of the galaxy young Gamora from 2014
just takes off and that sort of sets
them off on the plot for guardians of
the galaxy 3 or as guardians of the
galaxy which I'll talk about in a second
but during the battle after Captain
Marvel briefly bites Thanos he finally
gets his hands on the stark tech
gauntlet but before he can snap Iron Man
yoinks all the in
Finity stones to his gauntlet and snaps
Thanos and all of his forces from 2014
away with his iconic line I am Iron Man
but because the power of the Infinity
Gauntlet is too much for his normal
human body to handle it effectively
kills him but he lives long enough to
get good buys with a couple of the big
characters like Spider Man I don't feel
so good mr. stark Pepper Potts and
Rhodey so she basically tells him you
can rest the job is done we'll be okay
they have a funeral scene for him with
all the Avengers characters in the other
main characters attending even ty
simpkins
character from Iron Man 3 remember he
was the little kid from Iron Man 3
everybody was asking who's that teenager
standing next to Captain Marvel that was
who that was not only has it been a long
time since the events of that movie it's
also 5 years later it's 2023 so Cassie
Lang is still a teenager at the end of
the film there's a scene of them playing
a message that Iron Man left from before
the time travel plans started as a sort
of final message to them just in case
things didn't work what his hopes were
as they go to a bunch of different
scenes around the world of everyone
going back to their people like you see
black panther in Wakanda it was sort of
like the end of the special edition Star
Wars where they go around to the
different cities and you see the
celebrations after the second Death
Star's blown up one of the scenes is
Spider Man going back to school at
Midtown high
the next day presumably and reuniting
with nedley's looking like they both
kind of been traumatized like I'm so
happy to see my friend again after being
snapped the biggest question that I've
seen the last couple of days on all my
videos and my feeds is is how are they
gonna address this during spider-man far
from home all the kids are the same age
they're on this class trip to Europe how
they not talking about this trauma that
they experienced in last year Amy Pascal
said the Spider Man far from home picks
up minutes after the end of Avengers
endgame so I think that's what she's
talking about here where you see him
walk into school at the end of the film
I think the only way this works is if
all the kids in Peters group here that
are on this class trip during spider-man
far from home got snapped so they didn't
move forward in school maybe there were
a couple kids they went to school with
who did not get snapped to her now five
years older but that's just a really
easy way to explain how all these kids
are the same age and spider-man far from
home can still take place after the
events of Avengers endgame there's a
scene with happy in the trailer where he
says you're all alone now
they haven't come right out and said the
iron man is dead during one of those
trailers hopefully there'll be a new
trailer that will give us some more
details about that but think about all
the character development the Spider Man
got between Avengers infinity war in
Avengers endgame it would be a huge
middle finger if they released a movie a
couple months later just completely
ignoring that so I think they do have a
way of addressing it at the very
beginning of Spider Man far from home
one of the other final scenes of the
film is Thor joining the guardians of
the galaxy passing leadership of Asgard
two Valkyries saying it's time for me to
be Who I am rather than who I'm supposed
to be Valkyrie is thus named queen of
Asgard Thor officially joins the
guardians they joke about it being as
guardians of the galaxy together again
like Thor was just waiting to rejoin
them this whole time they have a funny
standoff about who's going to be their
new leader because technically Thor was
king of Asgard and he's the most
powerful member of the team at this
point so star-lord is a little
intimidated they're just carrying
forward the comedy of the scenes that
they had during infinity war when they
first picked him up and star-lord was
super intimidated by him but the whole
idea is is that star-lord wants to find
that younger Gamora from 2014 and win
her over to their team so that sounds
like it's gonna be the plot of guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 or as guardians of
the galaxy whatever they decide to call
it so the cool thing about that is that
you have Thor in that movie he'll
probably lose all that weight before the
movie starts but you have someone who's
powerful enough to counter Adam warlock
who's getting ready to hatch out of his
cocoon during that film we'll talk more
about future Marvel movies when I do
Marvel phase 4 videos in the next week
we're still kind of working our way
through the end of the movie at this
point like I said Lord of the Ring style
there are several different endings to
the film because everyone has to get
their goodbyes the deal with the version
of Loki from 2012 that escapes with the
tesseract is that remember the changes
they make in the past
splinter new timelines so that's now an
alternate reality version of Loki that
would exist in present day potentially
so if we see another version of Loki pop
up in present-day who's alive it's gonna
be from an alternate timeline it won't
be our version of Loki from infinity war
who still did at the end of Avengers
endgame
so when Tom Hiddleston's Disney Plus
streaming service show starts in the
next couple of years I don't expect it
to be that version of Loki I think it's
gonna be a Loki set during the past
because we'll see him throughout his
alive popping up on earth
mischief sort of like a quantum leap
Loki show of him popping up across human
history throughout the ages just
influencing really big events in world
history then you have the Captain
America scene where he takes the
Infinity stones back to where they stole
them from to keep all those timelines
intact but instead of coming right back
he stays in the past with Peggy Carter
and they have that quote-unquote last
dance that she said she'd save for him
when he went into the ice he then shows
up on a park bench near the lake just
like he was waiting for them back to the
future to style if you remember the end
of Back to the Future to the dock stayed
in the past in the Wild West and then
arranged for a message to be sent to
Marty when it got to his time in
present-day the Captain America twist
breaks a couple of their time travel
rules that they had set up but
essentially he had just stayed in the
past and grew old with her he refuses to
tell them about the wedding ring on his
finger but we all know that he got
married to a version of Peggy Carter
they grew up together he had a family
with her he had the really nice life
that iron man told him to get he then
passes a repaired version of the Captain
America shield to Falcons saying try it
on and passing the mantle to him so
presumably we'll see him wearing his
Falcon Captain America costume in
whatever next Avengers movie they do so
Captain America is not dead at the end
of the film but any future contribution
from him in present day would be at Stan
Lee cameo level like you know shake his
fist or like have some inspirational
quote that he gives to younger Avengers
as for the logic of the twist like how
could he exist in that past timeline
without splintering out a whole bunch of
others the easiest way to explain it
based on the rules that they set up
earlier in the film is that once he
makes the decision to stay in the past
and they're dancing together that
creates an alternate timeline he stayed
in that timeline as he grew older with
Peggy Carter he kept the time-travel
suit and got his hands on some more Pym
particles from Hank Pym in that timeline
then once his version of Peggy Carter
died of natural causes he chose to use
his time-travel suit in the Pym
particles to come back and wait for them
on this park bench in the original
timeline that he came from
so don't drive yourself crazy trying to
explain how it is the Captain America
can exist in his own timeline because
remember nothing they do in the past
will change their future so he could do
anything he wanted to in the past it
would just create alternate timelines he
lived during one of those then
eventually old man cam
hop back to the original timeline that
he came from so that's how he winds up
on this park bench here our version of
Black Widow unfortunately is still dead
at the end of the film they explained
that they can't undo the soul stones
sacrifice professor Hulk even explains
that when he snapped everyone back he
tried to bring her back but it didn't
work
but he's still Professor Hulk with a
very messed up arm like vanos was at the
end of infinity war so he's still fine
to come back in future movies as
Professor Hulk the very final scene of
the film is them fading to the past
watching young cap have that last dance
with young Peggy Carter as their song
plays over the credits the thing about
the end credits is that there's no
traditional Marvel post-credit scene
teasing what's coming next but they
actually do that with a lot of the
scenes during the regular movie like the
underwater tremor that Okoye talks about
teasing Namor in the as guardians of the
galaxy Thor scene those are all versions
of what you would see during a
mid-credits scene like Oh wink wink
here's some big stuff that's coming up
down the road there is a very audible
sound of a hammer clanking on metal
three times it's the sound of Iron Man
forging the Iron Man mark 1 armor in the
cave during the first Iron Man movie the
reason they do this at the end of the
credits is for a couple different
reasons one to be an homage to the end
of phase 3 like the three clanks two to
pay honor to the original Iron Man movie
in the moment that started all this MCU
stuff in real life and three to wink at
the idea that someone in the future is
gonna forge new Iron Man armor so Tony
Peppers daughter Morgan Stark is no
proven genius but she's gonna inherit
Stark Industries someday and his legacy
so soon she's about four or five years
old at the end of the film
give her ten twelve years to become a
teenager it eventually maybe you see her
join a version of a young Avengers team
and become a new version of Iron Man or
Iron Heart or however you want to think
about it they're pretty much telling you
that no one is gonna pick up the Iron
Man mantle for a long time but because
it's 2023 in present-day
I don't expect them to do another
Avengers movie till 2023 or later which
means I saw it for years till the next
one but we'll probably hear more about
that this summer after spider-man far
from home comes out when they released
their official Marvel phase four movie
schedule so I realized there's play
still a billion other questions about
big plot twists during the movie or
logic
you guys have so I'll try to do more
videos talking about the timeline and
Marvel phase 4 in the next week but
leave all your questions in the comments
below my Easter Egg video for endgame
will probably post on Saturday at some
point congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last Marvel video
Susan Mohan please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details click here for my full Avengers
endgame review and click here for my
Game of Thrones season 8 episode 3
trailer video thank you so much for
watching I love you 3000 I'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]